Women always dream about romantic moments in their lives.
If you go to Melbourne in Australia with your wife or girlfriend, remember this!
The Colonial Tramcar Restaurant is Melbourne's star attraction.
You can take a tram ride and see the sights of the city...
...while dining on five-course meals with wine.
This can be very romantic and your wife or girlfriend would never forget this in her entire life!
In addition, how about giving a little explanation about this tram...
...while you enjoy the great food?
The story goes like this: Converted historic trams...
...were transformed into first-class restaurants with luxurious fittings of the colonial period.
The trams have modern stabilizers that allow a smooth ride...
...through the picturesque streets of Melbourne.
You would feel as if you are into the past and the present at the same time.
If you are in Melbourne, how about killing two birds with one stone?